le temps presse au japon le pays à la
population la plus vieille au monde plus
du quart des japonais en 65 ans et plus
et en 2060 ce sera 40 % de la population
les effets se font déjà sentir
me contrer la pénurie de main d'oeuvre
les japonais mise sur la robotique
takamura cash
à 60 ans il ya le vide et boîte toute sa
carrière
je veux prendre ma retraite dans cinq
ans et cette machine va me permettre d'y
arriver lance-t-il les charges sont deux
fois moins lourde selon lui avec la
crise démographique au japon la
compagnie at on écrit cet équipement qui
permet de soutenir les hanches et le don
lorsqu'on soulève une boîte comme dans
cette entreprise du ford osaka ce qui
permet d'éviter d'avoir plusieurs
employés en congé maladie en mouvement
vers le directeur de l'entreprise de
transport maritime pense déjà au futur
il est vrai que les bras de ses employés
soit aussi aidé par la robotisation
la compagnie à thoune il ya pensé ils
ont créé ce prototype d'exosquelette les
problèmes démocratiques japonais c'est
une occasion d'affaires pour eux et
créateur de ce rebond est évaluée à plus
de 2 millions de dollars canadiens
espèrent le voir lever des tuyaux et des
matériaux l'eau d'ici 3 à 5 ans dans ce
pays où l'on vend maintenant plus de
couches pour adultes que de couches pour
enfants
la pénurie de mai devrait aussi criante
dans le secteur de la santé dans cette
résidence de soins où l'on traite des
patients souffrant de démence une
maladie en forte croissance au japon on
teste aussi des robots contrôlés du bout
des doigts ce robot de toyota peut
reconnaître un objet au sol et joue un
rôle de soutien au personnel infirmier
puis me la remet l'équipe de tout y est
accrue sur hbo pour venir en aide à
l'être humain dit-il inglenook rallye au
genou ne faut pas penser que les robots
vont nous remplacer croit le directeur
adjoint de la résidence de soins mais
ils peuvent jouer un rôle clé ici à lula
il lui parle toute la journée
il reconnaît la voix des patients et se
rappellent de leur nom ils sont
convaincus qu'ils parlent astro le petit
robot
le compagnon de vie parle de la pluie du
beau temps selon les informations qu'il
va chercher sur le web
en plus de chanter pour ses nouveaux
amis
[Musique]
est ce que ces robots viendront prêter
main forte aux canadiens dans un avenir
rapproché
la population de la gaspésie des îles de
la madeleine et des provinces de
l'atlantique et plus vieillissante que
celle du reste du pays
il y à une pénurie de main d'oeuvre dans
bon nombre de secteurs
les ministres de la santé du québec
connaît bien le potentiel des robots
pour les avoir déjà vu à l'oeuvre
on voit aujourd'hui que la fission
rattrape pas c'est souvent la réalité
maintenant oui ce que vous avez vu est
quelque chose qui est spectaculaire et
s'accroche progressivement vers une
application réelle et représentants de
toyota seront d'ailleurs à montréal en
juillet pour participer à une
compétition internationale de robotique
ce sera une belle occasion pour ceux qui
veulent en apprendre davantage sur cette
technologie ici ferrer pu rogner
radio-canada tokyo